growth and development which transformed
everything from medicines to transport
and brought Prosperity across the world
we are at the Tipping Point of another
Revolution that has the potential to
transform
the way that all our mode of Transport
are powered is changing at PACE
hydrogen fuels NetZero emission Vehicles
sustainable Aviation fuels green
shipping corridors
those markets that change first and have
the potential to grow fastest will go
the furthest
we want UK business to lead the way on
this new clean growth Revolution
so that's why we're investing record
amounts in our roads in our Railways and
in future green Transport Solutions to
provide the conditions that will make
sure business can grow on the back of
clean transport
building the vital connections that will
open up access to jobs education and
housing across the whole of the United
Kingdom
this government is unashamedly going for
growth
growth is key to delivering jobs higher
wages and more money to invest in our
world-class Public Services
and a key part of achieving that growth
is keeping our promises and delivering
for the people
speaking as the Member of Parliament who
has campaigned for dueling the A1 a road
investment first promised in 1992 and I
was elected on that promise delivering
on our promises is firmly on my mind
the A1 is just one example the a303 is
another one of the main gateways for the
Southwest it acts as a bottleneck to
growth so we are committed to getting
these Road Solutions delivered
delivery is the key
something my fantastic ministerial team
are all focused on Kevin Foster is
taking on the challenge of modernizing
our railways Catherine Fletcher will
deliver the roads the Prime Minister has
asked me to accelerate which the
chancellor announced in his growth plan
baroness severe will work to decarbonize
the aviation industry and Lucy Fraser
will be working on the future of
Transport making it fit for a modern
world
and our parliamentary private
secretary's Marco longy anti-brown and
Damian Moore in the whips office are
going to help us to stay on track
as a rural consistency MP do you know
one of the most common issues that gets
raised with me is the state of my local
roads
indeed I became very popular overnight
with many colleagues when I was given
this new posting because I think we all
have constituents raising similar issues
with all of us
that's why we have set aside a pothole
fund to repair 10 million potholes a
year
thank you
so Motorway or local Street this is a
government which will invest so that our
country can grow
we are a team that is determined to get
Spades into the ground at PACE
conference we've got a lot to do it's
time to get Britain moving thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome the
Secretary of State for Health and Social
care and Deputy Prime Minister Therese
coffee
foreign
I'm delighted to be here in Birmingham
for my first speech as Secretary of
State for Health and Social care and as
Deputy Prime Minister
I was here just a couple of months ago
for the Commonwealth Games and I was
absolutely Blown Away by the games
themselves and also how how by how this
city has been transformed since we were
last here and that is thanks to
conservative mayor Andy Street
thank you
Andy has shown that being ambitious for
the people and communities he represents
getting on with the job at hand and
focusing on delivery is exactly what our
voters want and why he was re-elected
resoundingly
conference as a conservative government
we believe in the Great British people
and we are ambitious for our country
despite severe challenges facing the
global economy in the wake of Putin's
illegal evasion of Ukraine and the
Aftershock of covid
now is the time we must come together to
tackle the issues that we have long
faced
and we will take this decisive action to
get Britain moving again
I've been getting Britain building to
channeling investments into local areas
to helping families get on in life we
will deliver deliver
conference on National Health Service
has the admiration and gratitude of the
British people particularly for getting
us through covert the doctors the nurses
The Midwives the paramedics the chemists
the cleaners and all the clinical and
support staff as well as the carers
working in care homes or in our
communities
they regularly go the extra mile they
are the pride of Britain
the NHS is and always has been a
national Endeavor that was set out in
1944 when it was a conservative
politician Sir Henry willink who put
forward the proposals for a National
Health Service
that's right a conservative MP from my
home city of Liverpool who conceived the
NHS a good omen I think
um
and I continue to be proud of the many
doctors nurses and dentists serving as
conservatives in Parliament far more
than we see in the labor party
and it's because of our conservative
party's commitment to the NHS that we
will be spending
173 billion pounds this year on Health
and Social care in England alone up from
124 billion pounds when we entered
office in 2010.
this has resulted in more doctors and
nurses than ever before
but as health secretary it's my job to
be honest and to level with you about
the scale of challenge ahead of us
and frankly I won't be turning to labor
for Solutions
[Applause]
the labor party running the NHS just
look across the border into Wales where
around 60 000 patients are still waiting
for more than two years for treatment
higher than last year
this isn't the time for Brick bats
though it is precisely because
Healthcare matters so much that we need
to have an honest discussion and be
prepared to hold the NHS to account
forging a partnership with them focused
on delivery not Dogma
so let's be honest
While most patients receiving care in
our NHS have a good experience too many
do not
whether it's the 8 A.M scramble to see a
GP or the long waits to get tests or
treatment
or the struggle to see an NHS dentist at
all
much of this has been made worse by the
pandemic and I must level with you
backlogs are expected to rise before
they fall as more patients
come forward for diagnosis and treatment
but this isn't just about covert
there is still too much variations in
patient experience
I saw that for myself in this July when
I went to a e I waited nearly nine hours
to see a doctor before being asked to
return the next day for treatment
now I knew from previous experience that
would be too late so I took myself to a
different hospital and was treated that
same day
that is the sort of variation we see
across the NHS from two hospitals just a
couple of miles apart and it must change
that is why my first job in the
department was creating our plan for
patients which puts the needs of
patients front and center
our new plan for patients deliberately
places an emphasis on Primary Care the
gateway to the NHS for most people it
empowers doctors and nurses by reducing
bureaucracy which gets in the way of
them doing their jobs and it seeks to
improve performance across the country
by unlocking data
now you may have heard a b c d on my
immediate priorities
and no conference time wasn't
broadcasting my a-level results to the
nation
nor was I reciting a new hip-hop beat by
Dr Dre
those four letters represent my
commitment to focus resolutely on the
issues that affect patients most
ambulances backlogs care doctors and
dentists
um
and with my excellent ministerial team
Robert generick will Quince Neil O'Brien
Nick Markham and our very own in-house
ministerial medic Dr Caroline Johnson
together we will focus on the issues
that affect patients most to deliver
their priorities and be their champion
starting with a for ambulances
access to Urgent Treatment can be
life-saving when people phone line nine
because they think they or their loved
one is having a heart attack or stroke
they want to know help will come and
will come soon
let's be clear average waiting times are
too long so we are increasing the number
of 999 call handlers and we must also
get ambulances back on the road from
handovers at hospitals
so we are placing a laser-like focus on
our most challenged trusts because as we
saw last winter nearly half of all
Handover delays were in just 15 trusts
we also know to be able to admit more
patients we need to open up more space
in hospitals so we are acting
immediately to create more capacity the
equivalent of seven thousand more beds
this winter
but it's not just capacity in all
hospitals we need it's also in our
communities to help support people who
could be cared for more appropriately at
home or in a care home rather than being
kept in hospital unnecessarily
that is why the C for care is such an
integral part of our plan and why we
have invested a further 500 million
pounds this winter so local councils and
the local NHS can work together to
tackle delayed discharges
it isn't all about emergency care though
it is also about diagnosis and treatment
and that is where we go back to the the
backlogs
the waiting list for plant care made
worse by the pandemic currently stands
at about 7 million
this includes people waiting for
diagnosis to know if they need any
treatment at all
while in England we have now virtually
eliminated weights of over two years we
are speeding up our plans to roll out
Community diagnostic Centers as well as
new hospitals and we will maximize the
use of the independent sector too when
patients are waiting too long for
treatment
lastly but key is D for doctors and for
dentists now
I think it's perfectly reasonable when
people need to see a GP they should
expect to do so within a fortnight of
course I would like to be more ambitious
and while I will not be prescriptive on
how GPS interact with their patients I
am clear
patients must be able to see their
doctors promptly
now to help
now to help achieve these priorities I
will publish a lot more information for
patients so they can see how their local
NHS is performing including their GP
practice and on access to NHS care and
treatment
another key element is personnel
I've listened to why people are say they
are leaving the NHS or what is holding
them back from offering more services
and I am responding
I'm empowering GPS to use their funding
more flexibly for the recruitment of
more support staff and making
significant changes to pension
Arrangements I'm extending the emergency
clinical register so that health
professionals who have come out of
retirement can continue to practice for
a further two years I'm opening up more
prescription capability and services to
pharmacists I'm investing in I.T for
telephony and digital appointments and
I'm making it easier for clinicians
registered outside England to be
accredited to get to work more quickly
treating patients
it is frankly Bonkers that we have
restrictions on the recognition of
doctors dentists and nurses within the
UK itself that is why I'm laying
regulations next week which will allow
the general Dental Council to get on
with accrediting dentists to work right
across our United Kingdom so we can have
Oasis of Oral Care rather than Dental
deserts this is all on top of our
existing commitments to boost their
Health and Care Workforce including our
Manifesto pledge to recruit fifty
thousand more nurses by 2024.
conference
whether you live in a city or a town in
the countryside or on the coast
this conservative government will always
be on your side when you need care the
most
conference this is just the start of our
Ambitions for Health and Care our plan
informs patients and empowers them to
live healthier lives because we know
prevention is better than cure it is
right we continue our longer term health
approach strengthening mental well-being
and resilience as well as the physical
health of our nation because that is
also good for the economic health of the
nation
we have a record number of people in
work on the payroll but there are many
vacancies still to be filled
we know work is good for you both
physically and for mental well-being as
well as putting more pounds in your
pocket
that is why I will strive to support
those not working now due to ill health
to help them to start stay and succeed
in work building on the prime minister's
pledge to have more mental health
support in communities
because together we can deliver a
healthier more productive Society all
the stronger to help grow our economy
as the Prime Minister said on the steps
of Downing Street she has three clear
priorities growing the economy tackling
energy security and costs for households
and businesses and the NHS
when I first went into the department I
asked what was the biggest risk what
what biggest risk was this winter
and what we could do to help
I was told help with energy bills so
older people would not worry about the
cost of turning on the heating and for
Health and Care Providers too
the Prime Minister and the chancellor
listened they acted they have delivered
and we need to act on growing the
economy too we need a strong economy to
have a strong NHS we need a resilient
sustainable economy to have a resilient
sustainable NHS and we need a
compassionate and considered
conservative government to deliver
deliver
and
and together conference that is exactly
what we will do thank you very much
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
conference how are we feeling today
oh come on that was rubbish how are we
feeling today thank you very excited
that's what I like to hear well thank
you for joining us for this very
exciting leveling up panel as a newly
appointed leveling up Minister this
isn't just something that I am
passionate about this is something that
UK government is very passionate about
with leveling up absolutely at its heart
I would never have taken on this job if
I didn't think that that was the case
because leveling up is about making sure
that we are spreading opportunities
right across this country so that
whether you're from Bishop Auckland or
whether you're from Brecken and Radnor
you have the best opportunities to get
on in life and I'm delighted today to be
joined by a wonderful panel of excellent
guests including the Secretary of State
for Scotland Alistair Jack get in the
hands thank you
the MP for Brecken and radisha and PPS
to the Deputy Prime Minister Faye Jones
foreign
office Minister Malcolm offers
so Alistair starters off what are your
thoughts on leveling up
well as you said in your introduction
it's a uk-wide mission it's incredibly
important that we I mean as the as Boris
Johnson used to say you know opportunity
was not equally spread across the United
Kingdom but but Talent was that's what
we know and that's what we have to
address and in Scotland we're very
fortunate that
with a mixture of Project funding we've
got two billion pounds of funding
currently committed to Scotland and you
know we're just we're all about
delivering for local communities
delivering on their priorities creating
jobs improving the economy we allow the
leave the SMP to be obsessed with
separation with breaking up there are a
sole Mission they're failing on public
services and we see that in Scotland and
education on Health on drug debts on
many things
our focus is very much just that the UK
government is present in Scotland and is
delivering for people at a local level
and that is leveling up absolutely say
well I think we've seen a bit of a
journey on both the UK government and
the Welsh government working together
over the last years we've seen the best
and the worst I think during the the
peak of the coven pandemic when you
really saw political gamesmanship from
Mark Drakeford and I think backed up by
counterparts in Scotland as well you
know that was really not what we want to
see you know at the end of the day
Alastair is absolutely right delivery is
what our constituents right across the
country are conservative they don't care
who's delivering for them they want to
see a measured standard of improvement
in their lives and I think now we are
actually in a good place we finally got
the Welsh government to come on board
with the leveling up agenda and we can
see they are starting to put their
gamesmanship behind them so I think
that's that's really positive and for
someone someone who represents
constituency which has 65 miles of
border with England we look Over the
Hedge and can see things are working
better in England that I really want us
to embrace that agenda in Wales and
fingers crossed in a couple of years
time when we've got an opportunity to
have a conservative government in Wales
and we'll have two conservative
governments at either end of the M4
really working for Wales I think that's
when we'll see real change I know you
guys we're all going to be out there
aren't you delivering those leaflets and
knocking on doors in Wales to make sure
that that happens Malcolm your thoughts
I think on the Scottish point of view
this is one of the most important
initiatives that UK government I have
have put forward and it is it's
fundamentally going to strengthen the
union because what we're seeing here is
that we want as I said before
opportunity has not been shared
throughout the UK but Talent is is
everywhere and in Scotland there's been
a narrative pushed by the Scottish
national party that Scotland was treated
badly and differently by by the UK and
in fact quite the opposite but this is
some this is an issue that shows us that
we are the same opportunity been given
to all regions of England that has also
been given to Scotland and what we've
discovered is of the 32 local
authorities in Scotland many of them
were not run by conservative majorities
30 of those councils are are bidding for
leveling up many of them are SMP
controlled councils and they're saying
to us you know what we haven't seen
anyone from the UK very much for the
last 20 years and you're in town you've
got good ideas you've got money we want
more rather than less engagement from
the UK government so it's been a
brilliant Initiative for us
brilliant well on this snazzy new policy
we have also on investment zones but
also on freeports
tell us about those tell us about the
potential they have for delivering in
Scotland
well again you know it's about
Scotland's two governments working
together and on freeports we're a bit
behind the curve I was very fortunate
earlier in the summer to go and visit
Ben houchens teaside tease Works report
which was inspirational and he already
had let 50 acre sites to people the I
think on the 7th of July they were
cutting the first Turf for Sears but
more than that he there was a 1045 meter
deep water key going in and you will
know all these things from being from
that part but it was so impressive to
see but it but for me also depressing
that they had such a head start because
we had spent the thick end of 18 months
negotiating with the Scottish government
to agree a Freeport strategy for
Scotland we've now got there we have uh
five bids from orkney Peter Ed and
Aberdeen uh the Clyde the fourth and
Inverness and chromity and
we're now at a position where we can
we're ready to and that we've just we've
decided the winners if you like we we've
agreed with the Scottish government
we're ready to announce those winners
and we'll be doing that imminently
but I want also to offer those five
areas in investment Zone status which
will give them other advantages to go
alongside and actually I wouldn't be
upset if for instance Karen Ryan who
pulled out of their Freeport bids that's
at the I declare an interest here that's
at the West end of my constituency but
that's where the uh the sailings are to
learn and Belfast and I would love it if
with London Belfast they became an
investment Zone that would be a great
sort of Union message we like that
um and and it would bring hopefully more
investment and and more leveling up so I
would I I say this in advance because we
now have to work with the Scottish
government because part of the ized
offering is in the devil space so we now
have to work with the Scottish
government to get to the place where we
can take the investment Zone offering uh
out into and and have bidding and people
bidding for it and as I say the the five
bidders for freeports would be a very
good start but there will be other areas
that want to Bid And I think it will be
very important for the leveling up I
think it will make a huge huge
difference because this is it's not just
the tax breaks it's the inward
investment that will follow that that
will create better quality jobs and
improve people's livelihoods
absolutely and Malcolm you and I were up
in orkney last week talking to people as
part of the islands forum and it struck
me that there was an awful lot of
positivity around growth deals
we were there actually to talk mostly
about energy but we asked the uh the
delegates from all the islands in the UK
what was their major
with the change of government and their
their response was is leveling up still
going to happen and it was a
tremendously positive environment in
fact I saw you being footed you were
having selfies with a whole number of s
p counselors uh on the leveling up
agenda and I think what came through
what's coming through here is that this
is actually real devolution
this is not central government coming to
communities and telling them what's good
for them this is us going to local
communities saying what do you want in
your community if you take my community
remember Cloud which is considered one
of the most deprived areas in Scotland
the local people have decided the
projects they want to back and when the
council the chief executive Council said
to me that when they went out for
engagement with the community they got
the greatest response on leveling up and
anything they've done in 20 years and
that's supposedly within a deprived area
we're actually seeing they want they
want the tools to improve their lives
they're aspirational just like the rest
of us and we're in a position now
by allowing the local people to select
their own projects to give to empower
them to improve their own communities
and surely that's what the the basic
value of being a conservative is
and and say we need to talk about Wales
so you're elected back in 2019 so we're
still quite new slightly less
fresh-facing I think either of us would
like to be at the moment how have you
found the relationship between UK
government and Welsh government
well I think it certainly has improved
over the last uh three years you know we
have a constructive dialogue now I'm
really pleased at last they've come on
board with the idea of a Freeport and
that that bidding process is currently
underway and with any like we will have
at least one Freeport in in Wales
hopefully announced in the spring and
leveling up as well I think you know I
think the great great benefit of
leveling up is actually that we are
working directly with local authorities
in Wales which is absolutely fantastic
my local Authority Powers is one of the
largest areas in Wales but yet we never
received any European Union funding and
isn't this the great benefit of brexit
that we are actually able to take our
money and put it directly into Community
projects and as Malcolm correctly says
this is from the ground writer this is
this is bottom LED
um so I think you know not only is the
relationship between the UK government
and the Welsh government so much
stronger now despite despite the
occasional hiccup they're not you know
really fully engaged with the idea of
economic prosperity and more jobs and a
better standard of living but you know
the UK government is is dragging them
along we are in a much better place now
and you know I really am seeing the
benefit for the first time my
constituency got funding and we got
seven million pounds which probably not
not very much but in my part of powers
that is going to make a huge difference
we're going to be able to add better
facilities to theater broken Bracken
we're going to be able to build on some
Brownfield sites in plundering Dodd
Wells these are tired towns that need
love and need to come back into use
because I know that Wales is the best
part of the United Kingdom but
wow I'm pretty confident I'm pretty
confident
[Applause]
yes sorry Union yes that's it
um no but parts of Wales do need a bit
more love and you know we live in a very
rural part of the country which can look
quite beautiful but you know we mustn't
forget rural problems and Rural
deprivations I'm really really glad that
the UK government has got this
laser-like focus on on driving up
communities right across the country
brilliant and Alistair we've talked
about the relationship between the Welsh
assembly and the UK government what
about Scotland with those quite intense
political differences at times
yeah I I'm not going to soft serve this
it's very difficult I mean I I get up
every day as does Malcolm as the entire
Scotland office and we go to work to
strengthen the United Kingdom okay let's
be clear about that the Scottish
government get up and go to work every
day to break up the United Kingdom I
mean that's how it is
they
they want to separate I think we all
know separation is painful it's not
where we are we believe in strength the
United Kingdom and what we've got we've
had a breakthrough in freeports after a
very long negotiation I hope we'll get
one in investment zones but we also want
to for instance so Peter handy did a
very good union connectivity review and
there's a lot of good that can be done
out of that we want to work with the
Scottish government to deliver on that
we want to deliver small nuclear
reactors that help power the grid bring
down energy costs they're totally
against nuclear it's not the old nuclear
power stations these small nuclear
reactors do a job for the grid and the
idea that everything can be delivered
from Renewables is not realistic because
you know it doesn't matter how much
offshore wind you have in the North Sea
if it's a cold night in December and the
wind isn't blowing they ain't generating
any power so you do have other things
for the base loads grid whether a lot of
people like to hear it or not the base
load for the grid needs other forms of
support so there's that and there are a
number of other uh initiatives that we
want to work with them on we think all
of these things will either bring down
the cost of living to people and a good
example of that would be Gene editing so
at the moment we have a gene editing
build going through
Westminster it is not genetic
modification that was a complete
misunderstanding with the Scottish
government minister at the beginning
we've made this very clear Gene editing
is what happens naturally but you're
just speeding it up Farmers have been
doing it for centuries but actually when
you're facing issues around climate
adverse weather whether it's pesticide
problems applying pesticides and and
other other issues that farmers face
Gene editing can help you with that and
it can make your crops uh less expensive
to produce which brings down the cost of
food and it can obviously enhance the
yields as well and we want the Scottish
government to get on board with that at
the moment they're resisting it because
they're tracking EU rules and
regulations that to us is a mistake and
actually the national Farmers Union of
Scotland and many others the James
Hudson Institute who are the world
leaders on Gene editing and based in
Dundee they want the Scottish government
to get on board so again it's this
constantly working with them but trying
to persuade them to come on board
because these things are devolved we
have to respect that but equally Gene
editing can make a massive difference to
the the price of putting the shots and
to the productivity of farmers and our
Farmers want to be as competitive as
English farmers and we've got to back
them on that
well say I see you nodding along there
you have a huge farming Community yes
yes Brecken and radisha is is beef and
sheep farming country and equally we
have the same blockage in the Welsh
government they do not want to pursue
Gene editing legislation and Alistair is
absolutely right this could benefit all
of our Farmers this could increase our
benefit to the environment reduce our
Reliance on fertilizer which is an eye
watering cost at the moment so this is a
huge win-win and you know I really don't
understand what the Welsh government has
against Innovation progress better
environmental delivery and once again
you know with my 65 miles of abuser with
England we're looking across the way at
farmers and environments that are
getting a helping hand from their
government and we in Wales are not
getting that we are always being held
back by the Welsh government but this is
a particularly egregious example of how
they are standing in a way of farmers
and farming businesses in the
environment
but this is the point at which UK
government can step in and work with the
devolved administrations well not these
real tangible things because often it
isn't a tangible day-to-day things that
it talks about by the Welsh assembly and
the Scottish government so Mark I want
to touch on transport
how's that relationship going
well transport is devolved and so the
Scottish government will see that has to
be done only by them but then you have
trade routes that go through that
connect Northern Ireland to England
through Scotland and actually why is it
the why why we're not able to upgrade
for example is 75 when in fact that's
what the businesses in Ireland are
seeing in the business north of England
are seeing and so actually it's a
frustration that we're we we see we want
we want to work with you you yes it's
devolved but surely in this area there's
a wider UK initiative and I think that
that is a battle I think that we're
winning now uh also that's in in Europe
constituency you would know you know the
difficulty of that particular
conversation but the Hindu report was
actually designed to be a UK wine it's
very important to remind uh you know all
of us in all parts of the United Kingdom
that we remain united we still remain
one country that the evolution
settlement was meant to have certain
evolved areas where local the local
administrations that run better than
local affairs but for example we were in
orkney last week orkney and Shetland who
are now at the center of the the
revolution of wind power they want to
feel that they're at the center of this
debate and it's a UK debate isn't it we
didn't he we didn't feel that was
classified as a Scottish mat it was a UK
matter so I think this is very helpful
for us getting the the debate back to UK
wide matters
the tricky question the tricky question
what is your one main hope for the
future for Scotland
I was hoping you're going to start with
Malcolm I thought yeah
no no no no no no I mean it's not the
reason I wasn't going to pass the bar
and we might so so my My Hope for
Scotland is uh it is
does it have to be leveling up the
answer I mean personally I prefer it
forgiven that's my briefly so I think
it's leaked with leveling up okay I
think it's because I think the thing I'm
going to slightly twist and get my
answer in here the thing that is holding
we've seen the Scottish economy grow
slower than the English economy over the
last decade okay we know there's
uncertainty being caused in Scotland by
the SMP perpetually banging on about
separation
and we know that creates uncertainty for
business and we also have sculptors the
highest tax part of the of the United
Kingdom
and and what I would say is this is that
I want to see us win the case of the
Supreme Court which is coming up for the
10th of 11th of October which sturgeon
has taken to the Supreme Court I want to
see us win that win it well because I
believe the 1998 Scotland act it was
very clear what was reserved and what
was devolved Mark was just touched upon
that so I want to see us win that case
strongly I don't I sturgeon said that
she intends to have a referendum on
October the 19th 2023 I want to get
through that date and where I'm
confident there won't be a referendum
and I want to put the whole matter to be
put to bed and for the SMP to recognize
that actually focusing on the economy
and the things that people go to bed at
night worrying about that's the leveling
up agenda people don't go to bed and
worry about being part of the United
Kingdom they worry about their jobs or
their children's education or their
parents health or whatever it may be
those are the things they worry about
how much money they've got to spend et
cetera Etc we know all the that's what
people go to bed worrying about they
don't go to bed worrying about being
part of the United Kingdom and The
sooner as SMP realize that and start
delivering on the day job the better and
that's my hope for stealthy absolutely
quite right
so Malcolm we'll stick on Scotland we'll
push for time so I'm going to give you
30 seconds of some Yorkie hope I imagine
it'll be quite similar well it's very
simple for me Scotland has eight percent
of the population of United Kingdom the
33 of the geography whatever we do we
have a solemn obligation to always punch
above our weight and we must always do
that for more than eight percent
whatever we do so whether it's energy
we're producing 20 probably of UK's
energy we have 20 of food and drink
exports in Scotland uh we have a very
strong position in financial service
over 15 of University grants or
universities let's Hammer home the
position allow the Scots to be proud in
the union because they contribute they
punch above the weight and the scores
are happiest in the union when that is
recognized
foreign
gosh I'll try and do it quickly all I
want for Wales is fairness I want to be
treated like every other part of the
United Kingdom to give you one example
we have 300 patients in England who have
waited over two years for their
treatment in Wales that's 60 000 people
it really is that bad and has been that
bad and and friends you know I I have
lived in opposition in Wales for 22
years and so you know I really feel this
horrendous sense of Injustice about
what's going on in Wales because they
are being shortchanged by a Welsh
government that only delivers on a very
small amount of uh area for the South
Wales valleys and parts of the Northeast
they they couldn't give a monkeys about
my part of mid-rural Wales so all I want
is fairness I think the only way to
deliver that is as I say two
conservative governments working at
either end of the country to deliver for
people in Wales we've been left behind
far too long brilliant well there is a
quarter arms for elections next year
thank you for your time and for your
interest I think we can all agree that
there are huge challenges ahead but I
like to be a bit more optimistic I like
to say that there are huge opportunities
ahead the only way we're going to grasp
those opportunities is making sure that
the default administrations and the UK
government are working hand in hand to
deliver true leveling York for every
part of this great United Kingdom thank
you very much
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome the Secretary of State
for Education kit malthouse and his
ministerial team
[Applause]
are you sitting comfortably
friends
of all the work we've done together as a
party and indeed as a nation over the
last uh 12 years in my view the work of
which we should be most proud is the
work we've done in Education
wherever you look there is a story of
progress and success
we now have of the 10 million kids who
are in school about 8 million in good or
outstanding schools that's an enormous
Leap Forward over the last 12 years in
literacy we now have about 82 percent of
kids at six reading fluently rising to
91 at seven we're at the highest level
at eighth in the world literacy League
table our highest score that we've ever
had these are enormous steps forward
10 years ago
a very small number one or a very small
about 60 of kids were taking science at
GCSE were now at 90 history and
geography at below 50 now at 80 percent
it's a huge step forward
and at the same time we've seen the
record numbers of disadvantaged kids
going through University over the last
decade as well as the incredible work
we've done to Turbo Charge the skills
agenda and the Effie sector opening up a
whole new area of choice for young
people
and so that story of success is
something which we as a team want to
celebrate with you uh over the next uh
two years but also reflect on the fact
that there's still an awful lot more to
do
right this huge organization is vast uh
franchise if you like of of UK of
England education needs constant
attention and constant pressure from us
as demanding friends uh to drive it
forward and we've set ourselves four key
missions
first of all on schools we want to be
much more assertive about intervention
and standards looking for excellence in
the basics attendance Behavior Reading
Writing maths you give kids those basic
qualities and they'll generally fly
and that means that we need to be much
more front-footed about talking to
schools about what they can achieve
we've seen as I said vast progress in
lots of schools but there's still
Pockets that need our attention
and we need to reflect on the fact that
there's nothing quite as persistent as
people hanging on to mediocrity
us finding it challenging it working
with teachers bringing all the schools
up to the standard of the best will be a
key part of our mission
alongside that the Prime Minister has
asked us to play a big part in the
growth agenda and there are two key
areas that we can do that the first is
on child care
at the moment we have a child care
system which is not really performing
either for parents or indeed for
providers and so over the coming weeks
we'll be bringing forward new plans not
to Tinker with the system
but to provide really strong support for
those parents who want to go to work
want to take more hours want to return
to work but also critically support for
those families that want to make a
decision about having children you'll be
hearing more about that in the months to
come and then the second area of the
growth plan is of course this skills
agenda you know we've made heavy
investment in the apprenticeship scheme
there's still lots to do and Andrew's
going to be talking about that shortly
but driving forward degree apprentices
where we've now seen you know
professional firms now lawyers accounted
seeing the value of this attracting more
and more young people Landing T levels
launched successfully a recently now
expanding out across the country and of
course some of the boot camp work we've
done to shift people's skills
dynamically quite quickly like we did
last summer over hgv right nobody's
talking about the hgv license shortage
now because we put five or six thousand
people through the system very quickly
to get them into those skills so there's
lots of artwork that we can do there and
then the the fourth area which Kelly is
very focused on is around child safety
and safeguarding you know all of us have
had to hold back tears when we've read
some of those horror stories in the
newspaper star Hobson Arthur labino
Hughes right really Dreadful stories of
neglect and horror that some people are
some kids are subjected to that have
kind of caused us to question whether
the system is working properly and so a
sharp focus on getting into those 80 or
thousand children across the country who
are of concern and understanding what
more we can do to protect them we think
is absolutely critical
so success
story of progress
of millions of young people who are
going through a much better system than
they were over a decade ago but still an
agenda of intensity and work and in many
ways a kind of acceleration of the
mission the transformation Mission which
was begun 10 12 years ago has kind of
reached a point to which we need to
re-energize it and push it forward all
the thinking about education training
skills over the last 10 or 15 years has
been conservative thinking all the
progress has come from this party and
the work we've done with teachers we've
shown the country what can be done we
know what works now we need to spread
that to every part of the nation so
every child everywhere has the best that
we can give them and we'll all be
dedicated to that because at the root of
everything that we do not just in our
department but everything we do at a
government
needs to be one simple question that we
ask ourselves on a daily basis and that
question is will the lives of our
children
be better than our lives
whether it's housing or health the fight
against Crime or the growth plan
right they need growth the Next
Generation
if we could answer that question
positively then we will have done our
job and I think over the last decade in
education more than anything else
we can answer that question will their
lives be better than our lives with an
emphatic yes
so I hope those of you in the room
who've been Governors who are teachers
who've worked in education with young
people I hope you're proud of that work
I certainly am and I hope you'll hear
from us over the months and and weeks to
come that we will sing the Praises of
those who've done this work of teachers
of parents of schools of multi-academy
trusts as we spread that success to
every part of the of the nation
now to do that work I'm very lucky to
have a fantastic ministerial team and we
were given a choice today about whether
to give a speech or whether to to have a
conversation I thought was most useful
for you to meet this critical team who
are going to be part of the of the story
of success in the in the months to come
and so I'm going to ask each of them to
introduce themselves and talk a little
bit about their agendas so first of all
Kelly Kelly tolhurst we were elected on
in 2015. now you and I have shared a
passion for some time
um not just about schools but about
child safeguarding you know thinking
about some of those really awful stories
that we've seen and some of the frankly
Dreadful lives that vulnerable young
people live and about what more we can
do there to do to improve their lives
now as you introduce yourself could you
just talk about where you think that
could go what more we could do yeah um
well good afternoon everybody and uh
thank you Secretary of State and um as
uh the Secretary of State as our line
I'm Kelly tolhurst I'm the Member of
Parliament for Rochester extrude and
absolutely thrilled to be the minister
for the new brief schools and childhood
and this is a new brief that encompasses
all elements of a child's childhood and
a real Focus really trying to deliver on
our mission to make sure that every
child has a fulfilling childhood
now before I was elected as a member of
parliament I was a chairman of a small
charity running a children's center
within my Village actually where I live
where we were delivering Support
Services to parents
um for nursery places parenting courses
cooking courses things like that and
that's really what started my passion
actually about how how are we able to
develop policies and deliver services
that really support our our families but
also our our children so that's one of
the key things that got me started but
also
um my sister's a social worker and I've
worked with looked after children and
it's one of the things that has really
driven a me in politics ever since we
got elected to deliver for those young
people actually that don't have a great
don't have a big voice and that is our
looks after children and too often we
are seeing poor outcomes where I looked
after children and that's something for
me that is a strong driver to want to be
in this role and as the Secretary of
State asks the question about you know
how do we protect children from harm you
know how do we avoid those absolutely
horrific stories that we've all read and
and no one can not be touched by that
and we're lucky under the leadership of
our secretary of state and our prime
minister you know we are really clear
that we will be working tirelessly and
quickly in order to deliver a response
to the three big reviews that have been
take that have taken place the
independent uh reviewing to Children's
social care
um the national panel review on uh the
awful cases with Arthur and star and the
CMA report and we will intend to do that
but also launch an implementation
strategy
um
I I I'm I'm it's one thing that I can
achieve while I'm in this role is
changing outcomes for young people
particularly looked after children or
particularly those children who
um are living in families that do need
support and who don't get access to it
and I will be working tirelessly with
the under the leadership of our
secretary of state to achieve that
brilliant so a tighter thermal safety
net
very good
yeah no that's good a title thermal
safety net is exactly what we want now
next our newest recruit Jonathan gullis
known to many of you but a former
teacher
um Jonathan as you introduce yourself do
you want to talk a little bit about the
work we're going to do with teachers
obviously critical Partners in success
so many of them now doing a fantastic
job out there for kids that you've lived
it you've seen it perhaps as you
introduce yourself you could talk a
little bit about that agenda no thank
you kit and welcome uh everyone on hello
conference and
I've said it so many times and my
colleagues probably bored of it but I'm
never bored of saying it that I was
proud to spend eight and a half years as
a teacher both in London and in this
great city of Birmingham
and what really upset certain uh
Episcopal opponents is that I was also a
Trade union representative for three and
a half of those years as well working as
a shop steward hearing from our members
as a member of the nsuwt
and I wanted to quickly before I get to
what kid has asked is to explain why
education is so important to me
my mum and dad are the beneficiary of a
great education system but in different
ways it was my mother who got into
grammar school off their council state
in London that gave her the opportunity
to start her life it was my dad who
accessed the open university to begin
first in our family to ever get a degree
my mum and dad then worked incredibly
hard and were able to achieve success
that people in their local area said
wasn't possible it was education but it
reminded me time and again that made it
possible but the real reason I fell into
teaching because my dad was a teacher
and I was one of those that promised I'd
never followed my dad into the
profession but he was working with a
young girl called Hannah at Mabel
Pritchard School in Oxford whilst I was
volunteering in my second and third year
at University a girl with autism
and she was at the local scnd school and
I used to go and help on the school
trips as we went out and to spend nearly
two years with that young girl learning
trying to help her with her
communication teaching her very basic
skills but also teaching me about the
importance of making sure that every
child regardless of their situation
should be cared for should be loved and
should be uh have every opportunity
available to them made me realize that
it was teaching that I wanted to go into
and I was delighted to go into the
profession and never did I think back in
2011 I was doing my pgce that uh I'd be
sat on a stage as the minister for
school standards uh I know maybe at The
Institute of Education whether they're
proud to have his former alumni or not
I'm not sure but you know I was proud to
study there and learn a lot and I had
some great tutors Ben Hammond Jeremy
Hayward who were excellent at guiding me
through that process and you know for me
there's some really key priorities there
is the education investment areas that
were announced those uh 58 plus areas
that I know Diana worked incredibly hard
on before I entered the department we've
got those 24 priority areas and he won't
shock people that when Diana showed me
her spreadsheet of those schools that
have got two requires improvements or
inadequates that they overlap absolutely
with their priority education investment
areas and we're going to go in and rip
up I won't Nick Diana's number because I
know it's a favorite number to do but
when you hear the number of kids in
stock in those schools it's unacceptable
and we're not going to be ashamed to be
interventionists to make sure those
children have every opportunity because
every day in a kid's life loss is
another opportunity missed and we can't
allow that to happen
the other three areas are that we should
be proud as a party on the national
tutoring program and we haven't done
enough celebration of that over 2
million what I call opportunities given
to kids and I was out across Sandwell
and Wolverhampton only last week hearing
from kids and from teachers who have
benefited from the system enabling those
who are most disadvantaged to be able to
catch up on their learning and what was
most important to me was kids saying
that they had confidence to now sit in
the classroom and when they heard some
of those uh things whether that be in
science math or English talk to them
they felt that they belonged in the
classroom and that's what we've done
with the national tutoring program so
despite Labor's moaning and groaning
actually we've invested over 5 billion
pounds in capture which is enormous and
then finally as kit said about the
teaching profession we've just
accredited 179 teacher training
providers and that's because we're
unashamedly pro high quality
expectations of the teacher training
courses that we want making sure those
teachers not only have a evidence-based
LED curriculum for them to deliver to
their pupils but the right mentoring
that they desperately need because I was
blessed at black fence school for girls
under Pete Patterson and Lola Blanche to
get some world-class mentoring that
meant that I felt confident entering the
workforce but there'll be stuff that
like the early careers framework now
which is a two-year course with
mentoring uh and mentors trained as well
we've got these mpqs I've got 60 000
fully funded npqs I want every teacher
to sign up and take and they've been
again robustly looked at evidence-based
and evidence-led to make sure that we
have teachers delivering in the
classroom what we know Works rather than
what pedagogies at some in the past want
to live on this idea that will deliver
even though it continues to fail too
many children in our classroom my role
as kit said is to Champion teachers I'll
be unashamedly doing that but I'll also
be working with our trade unions to make
sure that we are out there looking at
how we can improve Recruitment and
Retention because we want every person
to come into this Workforce and realize
what a great profession it is well done
very good
very good and we're we're very proud to
have you Jonathan too it's great to have
you on the team uh a longest standing
member of the team Diana Baron who's
been a member uh in the department for a
bit now but very focused as Jonathan
said on this issue of kids in two RI
schools a spalling number but one that
we need to accelerate please give us
your your take on that number uh so
lovely uh to be here with you all and as
I have the enormous privilege of being
the education minister in the House of
Lords but as the Secretary of State said
one of the things that I'm particularly
focused on is those 700 000 children who
are in schools that are failing and have
failed for some time and it's a small
number in the context of the whole as
the Secretary of State said our
predecessors have done an extraordinary
job in turning around our education
system but if you're a child in the
their Secondary School in knowsley 50
percent of kids in knowsley are in
failing schools that's just not okay so
I'm relentlessly focused on trying to
bring that number down in partnership
with Jonathan and Kelly
and
there's a how there's what we want to do
which is bring that number down
radically over the next two years
there's how we want to do it which is uh
incentivizing quality and educational
outcomes for our children and there's
why we want to do it and as Lord Harris
who set up Harris Academy's
said you can make a mistake with your
first job you can make a mistake with
your second job your third job there's
still a fourth job but you only get one
education we want our children to have a
great education
very good
and then uh thanks last but not least
Andrew Jenkins who many of you will know
who's our skills Minister looking at Fe
and he now critical to our skills
Andrea Is the participation of employers
right we can lead a horse to water but
we can't make it drink as you introduce
yourself perhaps you could talk about
the work you're going to do to bring
more businesses in to offer
apprenticeships because we're not short
of applicants right lots of young people
want to do them we now need places
completely agree Secretary of State I'm
very proud to be part of this whole
skills agenda because to me we are
future proving our economy
um so I think a a big Focus for me is
actually looking at um as you rightly
said secretary of state is
um engagement with employers
um and how can we make the process
easier for employers because especially
if you're a one-man band where you wear
several hats it can't be a cumbersome
process it's got to be easy and on top
of that though what I'd like to focus on
what are the emerging Industries what
are the skills needed for our economy of
tomorrow as a lot of people might know
I'm very pro-brexit and I think this is
an opportunity I want to see these
homegrown skills and so and other things
I really want to focus on
um are
not only
um is access to education
um to me for too long the focus has
always been on on Academia and I think
that um you know we've got to be proud
of our Academia the universities you
know we have some of the greatest
universes um in this world and part of
my brief is International Education and
I'll certainly be selling um you know
this across the globe but but the other
aspect I think we need to actually
ensure that not only at teacher level at
parent level
um in throughout the education landscape
that vocational qualifications and
Technical qualifications are seen as
equally as important so reasoning that
esteem I think is definitely going to be
a focus and another thing we should be
proud of is
um look the amount of apprenticeships
we've had is amazing
um I was speaking to
um somebody who'd worked in the sector
for over 30 years and she told me that
under um under
Brown's government she's really trying
to push him to actually mention
apprenticeships once per year and and
look at us where we're at now it's
amazing we've currently got you know um
300 000 apprenticeships on the go at the
moment and but on top of that it's the T
levels I mean I went to the north west
and on t-level Resorts day and I wish I
could bottle that energy I saw there if
students were coming up to me and saying
it's changed their lives you know
getting that work experience there's a
great social Mobility maneuver you know
not everybody
um it's easy for middle class families
to actually get the work experience get
the internships in MP's offices but
working class backgrounds you know like
myself like many on this panel
it's much harder to have those
opportunities so to actually have the
work experience element that
apprenticeships and tea levels offer on
the CV we're really giving a better
start
um to those young people and finally um
oh we've got one person clapping oh
thank you
and and finally secretaries say um I'm
immensely proud of what we're bringing
in 2025 it's a lifelong learning
entitlement so
um if you think learning is not all
about school leavers and I think this is
going to be so important that what
whatever we're really changing the way
the landscape of education is funded and
this is really going to help those those
um people who look after loved ones
people who have been at the jobs Market
or was never trained before it gives
them some great opportunities and
flexibility in the Learning System so I
think that's an incredibly exciting
place to be brilliant well
friends the flashing number is telling
me that we're out of time but I hope
that you've got a sense of the
enthusiasm and commitment from the team
because as Jonathan said we are all
appraised with a fact that every day
counts those of us who've been lucky
enough to have children will know that
they don't hang about
they're gone in a Flash they grow up in
a blink
and that just a week a day a month of
substandard missed education whether
it's in College University or right
through the school system can have a
huge impact on their life chances
we've brought about over the last decade
enormous success a huge leap forward we
recognize that the work we're doing is
building on that success but now we need
to be impatient and demanding on behalf
of all those kids that we're looking
after making sure that they get the best
that they can the best foundation they
can to build a really fantastic life for
themselves in our wonderful country
thanks very much everybody thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the Lord Chancellor and Secretary of
State for justice Brandon Lewis
conference it is brilliant to be back
with you here in Birmingham
it's always a time that I enjoy and one
that I look forward to is I know so many
of you do it's a time for us to come
together as one conservative family to
reaffirm our common cause and I'm joined
today by my brilliant new ministerial
team who are here with us as well Rachel
McLean Mike freyr Rob Butler Gareth
Johnson and our pps's Aaron Bell and
Gareth bacon working alongside me with
our Lords Minister Lord Bellamy and
thank you to all of them for being here
and the great work they are already
doing in the ministry of Justice
foreign
our party has a long and proud history
and it's a party that has had that Pride
around our determination to deliver
freedom and opportunity
we have an unwavering belief in
integrity and individualism
supported by a robust and Unapologetic
approach to Law and Order Public Safety
and sound stewardship of the economy
Britain is known as a Bastion of Law and
Order and it's why people invest here as
well
Safety and Security for ourselves for
our families at home in our
neighborhoods in our schools and our
shops is the Bedrock that allows
economic growth to flourish
Public Safety means peace of mind
it means safer streets and healthier
communities
it means local investment and Economic
Opportunity
it's these priorities of safety of
security and of stability for everyone
in every community in every corner of
our country the we as conservatives
whole deal
at the Forefront of that effort are some
true hidden Heroes
they are the hidden Heroes of our
society many of whom are the backbone of
our criminal justice system
our prison and probation staff they work
hard so hard every single day to keep
the public safe
to keep us all safe from the most
serious and prolific offenders in
society
our dedicated course and tribunal staff
who enable Justice to be done in
courtrooms across the length and breadth
of our country join that team
and it's not just the system that
matters
is the people
now this has been a tough time for our
country and the criminal justice system
is no different
so we cannot shy away from that we have
to face down those difficulties
so that we can do what we are always
focused on doing
guarantee victims and survivors the
access to justice that they deserve
and as your law chance to a Justice
secretary I can promise you I will do
just that
now
like many of our Public Services the
judicial system was hit hard by the
pandemic
our courts were closed and Justice was
therefore delayed and a backlog of cases
built up
now we've got through the pandemic now
I'm determined that we get through those
backlogs I want to make sure that
everyone has Swiss Swift access to
Justice whoever they are and wherever
they are from
our justice system should never be we
will not let it be a lottery
and that's why I've already taken action
to address those backlogs now while
there are many challenges that have
contributed to that backlog the key to
unlocking our club.courts will be ending
the Barrister strike over legal aid fees
that strike action has had a devastating
impact on victims and justice has been
delayed in too many cases
that's why my first few days as Lord
Chancellor I met the criminal Bar
Association and last week we proposed a
comprehensive new package one that I
hope will bring a swift end to the
strike
we have to end the revolving door of
industrial action ending a cycle of
brinkmanship
we have to ensure all of us that we are
put in the criminal justice system on a
more sustainable footing for the long
term we owe that to victims
now that will also allow cases to be
heard more quickly for the benefit of
all including victims of some of the
most horrific crimes like rape and
serious sexual violence
we are overhauling the way the rape and
sex abuse victims are supported through
the whole criminal justice system so
that more cases can come to court
and more predators are put behind bars
a conference we have made some good
progress on this convictions are up by
two-thirds on 2020 and they're up by a
quarter compared to before the pandemic
hit
but I made no bones about it we have a
lot more to do I'm determined that we do
that and the government has set out some
clear actions already for the police
prosecutors and our courts to make sure
that more rapists are convicted and are
put away
we have invested significantly in
support for victims and survivors as
well
meaning that more support is there for
victims when they first report a crime
and more support when their case gets to
court
we want to reduce the trauma that's
involved in the trial process and
improve the quality and reliability of
the evidence that courts see as a result
of that
for example victims of rape and serious
sexual offenses can now pre-record their
evidence ahead of trial avoiding that
additional trauma of testifying in a
courtroom in front of your Q's attacker
we are also piloting the use of
independent advisors to guide people
through what can be a very difficult and
daunting process
and we're boosting the accessibility of
support with the new 24 7 rape and
sexual abuse supports helpline so that
people can access the help they need
whenever and wherever they need it
foreign
we all know that stamping out violence
against women and girls does not cannot
it must not end just at the prison Gates
it cannot be right that transgender
prisoners when convicted of serious
sexual offenses or those who have not
had reassignment surgery are housed in a
general women's estate
conference
this will end
we have a duty of care to All Those
Behind Bars
one case of a sex attack or
inappropriate relationship formed with a
female prisoner by a transgender inmate
is one too many and we've had too many
in recent years
our management of trans prisoners will
rely not just on common sense but will
also work on capacity if we need to
expand our use of the specialist areas
for Trans prisoners to further protect
women in prison then we will do that
indeed as a government we are committed
to creating 20
000 new prison places across the whole
of the system by the middle of this
decade and we'll deliver that as well
because Prison must be about the
punishment of the criminal and
protection of the innocent first and
foremost
depriving people who have broken our
laws of their Liberties to guarantee the
rest of us our cherished freedoms is
part of what prison is there for and
thanks to our Manifesto commitment to
accrue twenty thousand more police
officers we will be catching and
punishing more criminals and preventing
crime as we do it I'm determined to
ensure that our prisons keep up with
that but there is more that we need to
do to divert people away from prison and
away from a life of crime in the first
place
we know that hard and career criminals
are not born sadly they're made
we will avoid putting some of those
convicted of more low-level offenses
onto that conveyor bill by expanding our
world leading GPS tagging project for
neighborhood crime targeted at burglars
robbers and thieves who can be a scourge
of our communities and our neighborhoods
this compulsory electronic monitoring
and close supervision will mean that
police and our probation officers are
able to keep an even closer eye on them
when they leave prison their whereabouts
will be known 24 hours a day seven days
a week with the ability to impose robust
restrictions or where necessary
effective house arrest
we will maximize our use of new
technology technology like the GPS
tracking to reduce crime and protect the
public from those neighborhood Thugs who
too often blight our communities
in doing so we will reduce crime and
play our part in deterring and ending
reoffending for more people
these are common sense solutions to
sadly all two common problems
this government will also ensure that
the very worst offenders are locked up
for longer and our new prison places
will be vital in helping us do just that
and give a clear message to criminals in
society that they will be punished they
will serve time and our prisons will be
there to house them
foreign
Those who commit the most heinous crimes
and who commit those in a way that
continue to be a threat all of them must
be punished and the public need to know
that they will be protected from them
the guarantee of public protection must
be the overriding factor in our parole
decisions as well
so that we can secure the rightful
confidence of both the victims and the
public
now to do that I will make sure that the
parole board is more accountable and
more transparent about the decisions
that are made
just this week we are due to have the
first ever public parole hearing after
we reform the process earlier this year
and that is a big and a good positive
step forward
these reforms to the parole process will
all play their part in boosting public
protection and confidence improving
transparency and accountability better
supporting the victims of some of the
country's most horrendous crimes
better supporting victims and survivors
must also mean reducing reoffending more
effective rehabilitation
ERS need to ensure that we are making
sure that they appreciate the value of
hard work and personal responsibility to
have a chance to rebuild their lives and
play their part in society when they
leave prison
that means that those who have been in
prison paying back into their
communities and the country's coffers
it's based on the simple principle of
fans something we can all embrace
and we will do our part we will equip
prisoners with the training and the
skills they need to become active
participants in the jobs Market
we are and have just introduced new
legislation to allow prisoners to take
up apprenticeships whilst behind bars
for the first time
so that those prisoners can help build
communities whilst rebuilding their own
lives
convince these apprenticeships will give
them the skills that they need to get
onto the jobs Market to get jobs on
release and to pay their own way
now we know
across our economy that we cannot tax
our way to growth we have to make sure
that we are creating the the conditions
for the economy to thrive
our Legal Services industry is full of
opportunities for growth it is already
worth a positive surface of 29 billion
pounds to the UK economy it employs over
350
000 people and it is the foundation for
over 250 billion pounds worth of
international mergers and acquisitions
thanks to our values our belief in the
rule of law our traditions and our
history we are the world's Council and
the world's courtroom English law is
recognized around the globe
and I will work to promote our
exceptional Legal Services industry to
the world
and to see it recognized as part of our
new post-brexit free trade agreements
the critical importance of our whole
justice system to our country cannot be
overstated it underpins all that we do
all that we achieve all that we believe
in it impacts everyone everywhere
I take that responsibility to safeguard
and sustain that very seriously
because I know it means peace of mind
for all of us and the people we serve it
defines our quality of life
our justice system is the foundation of
what makes Britain Great and it is the
Envy of the world
for Great Britain is truly great when we
have Safe Streets
healthy neighborhoods and thriving
communities
that is what we as conservatives believe
in it's what we strive for and
conference is what this conservative
government will deliver thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome the
Home Secretary Suella Braverman
[Applause]
it's such a privilege to be here
being home secretary is not just a
tremendous honor
keeping the British people safe and
securing our borders are the highest
duties of State
our prime minister understands those
duties
and so do I
we stand for the law-abiding majority of
britons
and in doing so
I draw on a long tradition of
conservative home secretaries who are
willing to challenge failing Orthodoxy
they refuse to accept defeat
Michael Howard on his first day as Home
Secretary was told that there was
nothing that he could do about the
inevitable rise of crime
he disagreed and crime fell dramatically
he said that Theresa May couldn't Deport
Abu Qatar the islamist extremist but and
despite setbacks along the way she made
it happen
pretty Patel negotiated a groundbreaking
deal with our partners in Rwanda to
bring forward a new solution for the
challenge of illegal migration providing
protection in Rwanda for those that need
it whilst breaking the business models
uh the business model of people
Smugglers
I'm grateful to pretty and Boris for the
foundations that they laid
foreign
violent crime Has Fallen
as has overall crime excluding fraud and
online theft
and we are well on the way to 20 000
additional police officers
but a Home Secretary can never be in
complacent and some things still need
fixing
I'm pleased to be working with a
brilliant team of ministers who I'm so
pleased to see with us today Tom
tugenhart Tom persglove Jeremy Quinn
Mims Davies and Lord Andrew sharp
supported by our excellent pps's Gareth
Davies and Sean Bailey they all bring
talent and expertise to the home office
now the Prime Minister and I want to see
homicide
serious violence and neighborhood crime
Fall by 20 percent
some of our most committed and
courageous people serve in the police
in Belfast
in Belfast last week I joined police
leaders to pay tribute
to those officers who have died in
action
their ultimate sacrifice is one for it
for which we owe a huge debt of
gratitude
so yes I'm immensely proud of our police
now many on the left they want to defund
the police
well I say to the militants I say to the
anarchists and the extremists no I will
always back our police men and women
that's what being on the side of the law
abiding majority means
but we also need to be frank
when things go wrong
some police officers have fallen
devastatingly short of the standards
expected
we need to get back to Common Sense
policing empowering the police to tackle
the issues facing the public not
policing pronouns on Twitter or non-time
not policing non-crime hate incidents
that's why I'm very pleased to see that
greater Manchester police Hampshire
bedfordshire northamptonshire and the
Metropolitan Police have all promised
now to visit the scene of every burglary
but the law abiding majority expect
every Force to investigate every
neighborhood crime and so do I drugs car
theft vandalism and anti-social Behavior
cannot be ignored
perhaps the most unsettling and
unspeakable crime of all is rape
now as an MP and as the Attorney General
I've already seen firsthand how the
system needs to do better
I can't change things overnight but I
will not accept the status quo
now policing is a public service and
must be accountable to you the public
that's why it's right that we publish
League tables that show how well every
force in England and Wales is doing in
their fight against Crime
you all have the right to know and
greater transparency will drive up
standards
now the modern world inevitably brings
new challenges
our national security bill will ensure
that law enforcement and intelligence
agencies have the tools that they need
to stay ahead of the country's ever more
sophisticated adversaries
yet everything starts from getting the
basics right
we need Common Sense policing
unashamedly unapologetically on the side
of the law abiding majority
thank you
and that means that the mob needs to be
stopped
the police
the police must have all the powers that
they need to stop the protesters who use
Guerrilla tactics and bring chaos and
misery to the law-abiding majority
the human right to vandalize property
it's not my freedom of expression to
protest violently no you can't just
start a riot or glue yourself to the
roads and get away with it
yes friends as attorney general I had to
go to court to get some of these simple
truths established the judges agreed
with me last week in the court of appeal
in the Colston statue case and that's
why our public order bill will Empower
our police to stop this nuisance so
whether you're just stop oil or insulate
Britain or Extinction Rebellion you
cross a line when you break the law and
that's why we'll keep putting you behind
bars
foreign
s are a distraction
but make no mistake the left
are attacking our profound Elemental
values
wanting to replace them with the poison
of identity politics
thank you
and when this poison
seeps into the public sphere it
distracts our public servants from doing
their real job
that philosophy philosophy dominate the
labor party whatever secure starma
pretends
and that's why it only wrong
for the police to take the knee
it is wrong for them to join in with
political demonstrations it is wrong for
biologically male police officers to
strip search female suspects
and it's not just that pandering to
Identity politics is a huge waste of
time they need to stick to catching the
bad guys
now those who
dismiss political correctness as a
conservative obsession
I say this
I say visit Rochdale
visit Telford
The Grooming gang Scandal is a stain on
this country and it's what happens when
political correctness becomes more
important than criminal justice more PCS
less PC
now my other mission is to control our
borders
firstly legal migration
now I backed brexit
because I wanted Britain to have control
over my our migration and to cut overall
numbers
brexit was meant to give us a say on how
we determine our own migration policy
we should use our Newfound control to
deliver the kind of migration that grows
our economy for example that helps
projects that have stalled or built
friendships and relationships with our
allies
but the truth is parts of our system
aren't delivering we need to end the
abuse of the rules and we need to cut
down on those numbers that aren't
meeting the needs of our economy
and we must forget how to do things for
ourselves
there is absolutely no reason why we
can't train up enough of our own hgv
drivers or butchers or fruit Pickers
the way we build a high skilled
high-wage economy is by encouraging
business to invest in capital and
domestic labor not relying wholly on
low-skilled foreign workers
foreign
now this just isn't just about policy or
economics for me
it's intensely personal
my parents came to this country in the
1960s from Kenya and Mauritius
they loved Britain from afar as children
of the Commonwealth
it was Britain that offered them
security and opportunity as young adults
I'm not embarrassed to say that I love
Britain
no conservative is
not racist for anyone ethnic minority or
otherwise to want to control our borders
it's not bigoted to say that we have too
many Asylum Seekers who are abusing the
system
it's not xenophobic to say that mass and
Rapid migration places pressure on
housing public services and community
relations
I reject the left's argument that it is
hypocritical for someone from an ethnic
minority to tell these truths
my parents came here through legal and
controlled migration they spoke the
language they threw themselves into the
community they embraced British values
when they arrived they signed up to be
part of our shared project because the
United Kingdom meant something distinct
integration was part of the quid pro quo
now that didn't mean abandoning their
Heritage but it did mean adopting
British identity an identity of which we
should all be proud
this is the best place on Earth to come
and live in but I fear
I fear that we are losing sight of the
core values and the culture that made it
so
the unexamined drive towards
multiculturalism as an end in itself
combined with the corrosive aspects of
identity politics
has led us astray
I saw this when I went to Leicester
recent
a Melting Pot of cultures and a beacon
of religious Harmony but even there
riots and civil disorder have taken
place because of failures to integrate
large numbers of newcomers
such conflict has no place in the UK
or when we look at the prevent scheme we
see how cultural tensions within
communities are not being handled well
enough
the murderer
of our much list dear friend sir David
Amos
had been referred to prevent
but it couldn't stop him
we cannot as a people be cowed into fear
by vocal minorities who attempt to
undermine our Common Sense instincts and
as Home Secretary I will make sure that
prevent is fit for purpose the
law-abiding majority deserve nothing
less
and lastly we've got to stop the boats
crossing the channel
this has gone on
for far too long
but I have to be straight with you there
are no quick fixes and the problem is
chronic
organized criminal gangs are selling a
lie to thousands of people
many are drowning in the channel
many are leaving a safe country like
France and abusing our Asylum system
so what's our plan
firstly our work with the French has
prevented about half of all the
crossings now I know that that alone
will not work
so I will work closely with the French
to get more out of our partnership both
on the French Coastline and further
Upstream against the organized criminal
gangs
secondly we need to find a way to make
the Rwanda scheme work
thirdly we need to do more to get Asylum
Seekers out of hotels currently costing
the British taxpayer five million pounds
a day
and fourth we cannot allow a foreign
Court to undermine the sovereignty of
our borders
for a few months ago the European Court
of human rights in Strasbourg did just
that
by a closed process with an unnamed
judge and without any representation by
the UK a European Court overrode our
Supreme Court
and as a result our first flight to
Rwanda was grounded
we need to take back control
thank you
but friends I need to be honest with you
Strasbourg court is not the only problem
now everyone agrees
that we must fight the evil of modern
slavery
I'm immensely proud
of this country's Global Leadership
in protecting genuine victims
but the hard truth
is that our modern slavery laws are
being abused by people gaining the
system we've seen a 450 percent increase
in modern slavery claims since 2014.
today
the largest group of small boats
migrants
are from Albania a safe country
many of them claim to be trafficked as
modern slaves
that's despite them having paid
thousands of pounds to come here or
having willingly taken a dangerous
Journey on the channel
the truth is that many of many of them
are not modern slaves and their claims
of being trafficked Our Lives
and it's not just illegal migrants
since entering the home office I have
seen egregious examples
of convicted pedophiles and rapists
trying to gain the system
making last-minute claims of modern
slavery to block their removal from the
country
some have even gone on to commit further
crimes in the interim
in one case
a convicted sex offender from South
Africa had spent a year in prison
he was about to be deported from the
United Kingdom and lo and behold he made
a claim of modern slavery
our removal was stalled and in this time
he went on to commit a further rape
he's now behind bars
but when he's released well it's also
terribly predictable
in another case a pedophile from
Pakistan
received 10 years in prison
but at the end of his prison sentence he
put in a spurious claim
to be a modern slave
and even when he got through that
process
he made a second claim which blocked his
removal we simply cannot go on like this
we need to make sure that our system
strikes the right balance
our laws need to be resilient against
abuse whilst it's at the same time
ensuring that we help those in genuinely
need
we've got a proud history of offering
Sanctuary to those in need from
supporting the thousands of bnos fleeing
persecution in Hong Kong to welcoming
nearly 20 000 Afghan Nationals fleeing
war and Terror to offering immediate
Refuge to thousands of ukrainians
fleeing Putin's barbarism the UK and
this conservative government has always
been there to hold out the Hand of Hope
to Mo to those who need it most
but the law simply isn't working
it isn't working in the interests of the
British people or people who need our
help the most
our laws are being abused abused by
people Smugglers and criminals peddling
false promises
abused by people making multiple
meritless and last minute claims
abused by tactics from Specialists small
boat chasing law firms
this cannot continue
so conference I will commit to you today
that I will look to bring forward
legislation to make it clear that the
only route to the United Kingdom is
through a safe and legal route
and that's so that we can help support
those who need our help the most
including women and girls so if you
deliberately enter the United Kingdom
illegally from a safe country you should
be swiftly returned to your home country
or relocated to Rwanda
that is where your Asylum claim will be
considered
UK policy on illegal migration should
not be derailed by abuse of our modern
slavery laws Labor's Human Rights Act or
orders of the Strasbourg Court
and we will always of course work within
the bounds of international law but we
cannot allow this abuse of our system to
continue
and of course at the same time we need
to Stamp Out illegal working practices
we already have some of the toughest
penalties for those not playing by our
rules but we will redouble our efforts
to go after them
but I need to be straight with you
conference
this will not be easy
I cannot promise you a solution
immediately
we've all heard pledges and promises but
this problem is complex and entrenched
and there are many forces working
against us
the labor party will try to stop this
the lib Dem will go bananas
The Guardian guardian will have a
meltdown
as for the lawyers don't get me started
on the lawyers and I'm a recovery lawyer
[Applause]
but what I can pledge to you what I can
pledge to you is my total
and undeniable and unfettered and
unconditional commitment to doing
whatever it takes and despite those
obstacles I won't give up on you and I
won't give up on the British people
[Music]
okay
[Music]
thank you
it's very kind that I hadn't actually
finished
my goodness now if I don't get a
standing evasion at the end what do I
make of that
ladies and gentlemen friends conference
the time for words is over
now is the time for action it's time to
put the will of the hard-working
patriotic majority at the heart of all
we do it's time for the police to stop
to stop virtue signaling and start start
catching robbers and burglars it's time
to tackle the small boats no ifs no buts
friends it's time for common sense I
stand ready to serve you I stand ready
to deliver the time is hours the time is
now thank you conference
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
secretary James cleverly
foreign
a little bit of reshuffling going on
there
cool
oh look thank you uh conference it's
it's great to be back together great to
be back as a party as a family and I
want to say a big thank you to Jake
Berry our chairman because organizing a
conference is a mammoth undertaking and
a big thank you to our staff our
volunteers and of course a huge thank
you to you our party members
I loved being party chairman
I really did
I got a chance to work with you all I
got a chance to work with Ben my
co-chairman and I got to work alongside
Boris
and if I remember rightly
we did okay didn't we
we got an 80-seat majority we had a
great team of MPS elected from all over
our country and with boris's leadership
we delivered brexit he got us through
covid
and of course he led the world
in our support for Ukraine
it's a legacy that he should be proud of
and I was proud to serve under him and
it's a legacy that I know Liz truss will
build upon and I've seen her take bold
action when she was foreign secretary
her steadfast support for Ukraine and
the way she stood up to Russia her
passion
her passion
for the defense of our Union and her
determination to promote democracy and
freedom around the world
and as prime minister she is being bold
now helping with energy bills ensuring
that you can see a doctor promptly
reducing the taxes paid by ordinary
hard-working people across the country I
backed her from the start and I know
that I made the right choice
[Applause]
I am the foreign Secretary of the United
Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland
I have to confess it's still sounds a
little strange coming out of my mouth
but it is an honor a genuine honor to be
the face and voice of our country
overseas
I'm the okay yeah why not
I'm the UK's sales guy
uh and I like to think I'm pretty good
at sales
I mean I hope so I for most of my adult
life that's what paid the bills
but I know that however good A
salesperson I aspire to be the greatest
salesperson this UK that the UK ever had
was her late Majesty Queen Elizabeth
she was our greatest Diplomat our
greatest advocate our greatest champion
she genuinely was Elizabeth the Great
and I've now also had the honor of
meeting King Charles and I know he will
work tirelessly
to continue the work that she did and be
our new great ambassador
during the funeral week of her late
Majesty I was reminded
of the standing that our country has in
the world and when I travel on behalf of
our country I'm lucky enough
to see us
to see the UK as others see us
and I can tell you the view of here from
over there is really really good
[Applause]
it's not a terribly fashionable thing to
be proud of your country
but I am
to sue me
my mother chose to make this country her
home she was a young woman
from Sierra Leone who adored this
country then just as I adore this
country now indeed
indeed I am from immigrant stock on both
sides of my family as I say my mother
came here from Sierra Leone in
1966 and my dad's family came here from
Normandy in 1066.
look there will always be people that
talk down our country they will belittle
our achievements they will underestimate
our standing those self-loathing
keyboard Warriors who hate our country's
every success and pray for bad news
those are the kind of people who aren't
happy until they're unhappy
[Applause]
they're the kind of people who want to
stand on the sidelines never
contributing only moaning and bleeding
but that isn't us that isn't this party
that isn't this government that isn't
this country
we aren't commentators watching on the
sidelines saying oh I wouldn't have done
it like that we are players on the pitch
we make a difference we promote our
values we compete on the world stage for
the things that we know to be right we
believe in Freedom
we believe in the rule of law and we
believe that an aggressor cannot invade
its neighbor with impunity
and that conference is why we stand
shoulder to shoulder with those Brave
ukrainians defending their Homeland and
Britain has to have the Strategic
endurance to see this through until
their victory
foreign
February this year at the United Nations
I said
that if Putin was foolish enough to
attempt to invade Ukraine
the ukrainians would defend their
country ferociously
and they have done just that their
bravery and passion have been Amplified
by the arms and the training that the UK
has supplied and we will support them
until this war is won we will support
them until their territorial Integrity
is restored and we will support them
until the last Russian tank is dragged
Away by the last Ukrainian tractor
foreign
we need to have the Strategic endurance
to see this through to the end because
because if we don't
we send a message to every potential
aggressor that our resolve is fragile
and we cannot we must not we will not
send that message out into the world and
if you are listening to this speech Mr
Putin or Mr lavrov
let me be clear we will never recognize
the annexation of lahance or donetskazon
or zapparicia or Crimea
foreign
and
when Ukraine has won this war and they
will
then we will support them as they
rebuild their homes rebuild their
economy and rebuild their society we
will work with our friends and allies
around the whole around the world to
hold the perpetrators to account to
punish those who use rape
as a weapon of War to punish those who
knowingly Target civilian infrastructure
and to punish those who murder women and
children and we will not do this alone
we are a member of many International
groups
the Commonwealth
NATO the U.N security Council orcas the
G7 the G20
and I intend to build more alliances
more friendships more Partnerships
around the globe
that's why we have ambassadors and the
high Commissioners and diplomats in
hundreds of locations it's why I
and my fantastic team of ministers
travel the world trust me it isn't to
pick up those giant toblerones
because
although I do like those giant templates
look but when there is a war
our work on the international stage is
visible
and it's obvious
building coalitions of condemnation at
the United Nations for example
coordinating sanctions against those who
facilitate the war working to ensure
that the exports of food and fertilizer
from those Black Sea ports can continue
but much of what the fcdo does is less
visible
but no less important I've just returned
from a series of meetings in East and
Southeast Asia
I paid my respects at the funeral of
Japan's former prime minister Shinzo Abe
then I went to the Republic of Korea and
then to Singapore in each country I met
with senior ministers I met with members
of the international business Community
I set out the detail of the UK's
indo-pacific tilt
the indo-pacific is a part of the world
which is growing fast and through trade
agreements cooperation agreements and
our asean dialogue partner status we are
shrinking the distance between us
I spoke about the opportunities that are
available to us all and of course
I spoke about the role that China plays
in the region and around the globe
I made our position clear
that China could and should take a
different path
that it should adhere to the rules and
Norms of the International Community and
it should stop persecuting its people at
home and it should stop sanctioning my
friends and colleagues in the UK
Parliament
[Applause]
and was and whilst I was on the other
side of the world
fcdo ministers were in the USA in
European capitals in Africa and a number
of my ministers are overseas
as I speak
because we have to invest in our
International Partnerships patient
but effective diplomacy we invest time
we invest energy and yes we invest money
because that's how we generate influence
on the world stage and that's how we
drive improvements in the lives of
people overseas and how we improve the
lives of people here in the UK
the development money that we spend our
official development Assistance or Oda
it helps women and children who have
been brutalized by conflict it helps
prevent starvation we use our expertise
in financial services through the
British investment Partnerships to
amplify the money that we provide to
part fund green energy projects for
example or to increase trade or to
stimulate economic growth in some of the
least developed countries in the world
we don't just stand idly by and watch
problems happen we step in to improve
things we're not passive but we're
active it's the right thing to do it
helps people that need our help but it
also helps people here at home in the UK
why
because safe secure and prosperous
countries don't generate refugees or
hundreds of thousands of migrants
safe secure and prosperous countries
don't export terrorism safe secure and
prosperous countries are good trade
partners for us so obviously we want to
see more safe secure and prosperous
countries that is the active role our
Oda our official development assistance
plays
but
just because we look to build prosperity
in distant places
we mustn't forget the need to build
Prosperity closer to home
a good diplomatic and economic
relationship with the EU and its member
states is good for all of us
and we've worked closely on our
sanctions packages against Russia and
those Russians that have enabled the war
in Ukraine and I want to see more
cooperation across the channel and
across the Irish sea
and addressing the current problems with
the Northern Ireland protocol is key to
doing that and I want to ensure that we
restore the Integrity of the UK internal
Market I want to protect north-south
trade but I also want to restore the
balance of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement which has been disrupted by
the protocol
I want to see all the communities in
Northern Ireland represented again at
the Stormont executive so the devolved
government can be properly
re-established and I will work hard to
get that done last week I spoke to the
eu's lead negotiator vice president
maros sefkovic and we agreed on our
desire to reach a solution that works
for all parts of the UK especially the
people of North Island
so we have the Northern Ireland protocol
Bill working its way through Parliament
and in the meantime we continue to
pursue a negotiated settlement which
respects the Constitutional Integrity of
the United Kingdom and our single market
and supports the institutions of the
Belfast Good Friday good
[Applause]
as I've discussed
uh my fantastic
team of ministers
Vicki Ford Jesse Norman Leo doctors at
Goldsmith Tariq Ahmed Jillian Keegan
well you've got plenty to keep us busy
but
it is a job worth doing
promoting Global Britain on the world
stage and I know I know that I speak to
I speak on behalf of all the ministers
and all the diplomats and all the civil
servants in the fcdo when I say
it is an honor to represent the United
Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland on the world stage because this
is a great country a country I am proud
of a country I love thank you
[Applause]
all right
foreign